o sea un número primo impar itp el
siguiente conjunto de matrices
esencialmente si se viste el vídeo
anterior notarás que es exactamente el
mismo planteamiento tomamos un número
primo que no es el 2 y pp es el conjunto
de matrices que tiene el mismo número en
la diagonal y bueno tenemos el número b
aquí arriba y pse aquí abajo ahora a b y
c que son las entradas de esta matriz
son números enteros entre 0 y p menos 1
ahora la pregunta es cuál es el número
de matrices a en este conjunto tales que
su traza no es divisible entre p pero
que su determinante sí lo es ok y
recordemos que la traza de una matriz es
esencialmente la traza de a que es una
matriz que además nos piden que no sea
divisible entre p la traza es la suma de
estas entradas muy bien y bueno el
determinante ya sabemos calcularlo pero
el determinante
y es divisible entre p ok entonces vamos
vamos a empezar a explorar estas
condiciones nos dicen que la traza no es
divisible pero la traza es la suma de
las entradas de la diagonal que en este
caso es a massa entonces a massa que es
2a no es divisible no es divisible
/ p
/
muy bien entonces qué posibilidades hay
por ejemplo vamos a ver el caso en el
que si fuera divisible entre p entonces
dos ha sido xa es un múltiplo de p uno
de ellos tendría que ser por ejemplo el
cero no puede ser que el doble de a sea
cero lo cual me estaría diciendo que es
igual a cero este es el caso en el que
dos a si fuera divisible entre p ok
entonces la posibilidad es que no puede
ser cero verdad si fuera cero entonces
sería divisible entre p ahora qué
pasaría por ejemplo si si 2a fuera
exactamente p no esa es una posibilidad
y esto tampoco puede ser porque me
estaría diciendo que p que es un número
primo es divisible entre 2 pero entonces
como además p es un número impar pues no
puede ser divisible entre 2 así que este
caso lo descartamos que pasaría por
ejemplo si 2a fuera igual a 2 p
y simplemente ya lo tenemos que
descartar porque es menor estricto que p
a lo más puede ser perdón puede ser p -
1 y el doble de p menos uno es mucho más
chico que dos p de hecho es dos p - 2
entonces de entrada éste ya no puede ser
y lo mismo podríamos decir de 3a perdón
de 2a con respecto a 3 p por ejemplo 2a
siempre va a ser menor que 2 p y por lo
tanto va a ser menor que 3 p así que no
no puede ser igual a un múltiplo de p
así que la única opción que tenemos es
justamente que hace a distinto de 0 es
la única opción que tenemos ok ahora la
otra condición que nos piden es que su
determinante si sea divisible entre p
entonces tenemos que el determinante de
a
déjenme subir un poco notemos que es
hora que sea cuadrada - b por c esto es
a cuadrada
menos b por c y esto debe ser un
múltiplo entero de nuestro número primo
p así que uno este problema se ve un
poquito más complicado de lo normal
puede ser que quizás puede ser sencillo
pero al menos yo no he encontrado una
forma fácil de resolverlo la única o
sobre todo cuando uno está haciendo un
un examen y que tiene el tiempo encima
no no puede ponerse a hacer matemáticas
están tan profundas entonces son abejas
técnicas que podemos usar es la de la
fuerza bruta y es esencialmente
tomémonos un número primo impar
particular ok
tómense el número primo que más les
guste pero que no sea 2 y vemos cuál de
estas opciones funcionan para ese primo
particular yo les voy a ayudar eligiendo
el número primo y voy a elegir el número
p igual a 3 porque es el más chico es el
más chico que cumple con con ser impar
verdad
es decir que no sea 2 entonces no
tenemos cuáles son las opciones que
tenemos para p
3 ok entonces sabemos que a no puede ser
0 ya lo más es 2 entonces a puede ser
igual a uno oa puede ser igual a 2 son
nuestras dos únicas opciones en este
primer caso qué pasa con el determinante
el determinante de a es a cuadrada que
es 1 al cuadrado que es 1 - de porsche y
esto debe ser un múltiplo de 3 verdad es
decir un múltiplo de bp que en nuestro
caso es 3 ok entonces tenemos varias
quizás tenemos varias opciones vamos a
ver la primera de ellas es que sea igual
a 0 verdad 3 por 0 entonces una opción
es que 1 - veces sea igual a cero de
aquí tendremos que veces tiene que ser
igual a 1 verdad para que la resta nos
dé 0 y si me x se tiene que ser uno
quiere decir que b tiene que ser 1 y se
tiene que ser 1 verdad porque son dos
números
entonces de aquí ves igual a 1 y c es
igual a 1 y por supuesto recordemos que
a es igual a 1 aunque entonces esta es
nuestra primera opción
la segunda opción si nos damos cuenta si
veces algo más grande que uno entonces
la resta tiene que ser algo negativo muy
bien si tiene que ser algo negativo pues
tiene que ser menos 31 - bc tiene que
ser menos 3 y tú dirás oye pero a mí la
divisibilidad solo me lo enseñaron con
números positivos bueno esencialmente
aquí estamos diciendo que qué esta
diferencia sea tres veces un número
entero en particular puede ser menos 1
para que nos dé menos 3 y se vale es
válido muy bien entonces si consideramos
la divisibilidad digamos extendida
números negativos tenemos esta
posibilidad aquí que nos está diciendo
si sumamos 3 de ambos lados nos queda 4
y si sumamos veces de ambos lados nos
queda que bc es igual a 4
y ojo tú a lo mejor podría pensar en qué
bueno tomemos de igual a 1 y se igual a
4 o al revés sin embargo hay que
recordar que estos números deben ser
menores o iguales que 2 muy bien
entonces no podemos tomar uno que sea
igual a 4 así que ese caso no no queda y
solo nos queda entonces que ve es igual
a 2 y c es igual a 2 y por supuesto
repetimos qué
es igual a 1 entonces tenemos estos dos
casos para cuando es igual a 1 y
realmente no puede ser por ejemplo que
uno menos vez sea menos 6 porque ya
tendríamos que restarle ya bueno veces
lo más lo más que puede ser es cuando
ves igualados y se es igual a 2 que es 4
entonces lo menos que el menor valor que
puede tomar este este número es menos 3
ya no puede tener tomar valores más
chicos vamos a ver qué pasa con la
igualados aquí vamos a tener que el
determinante es a cuadrada que en este
caso es 44 - veces tiene que ser un
múltiplo de 3 verdad tres veces algo
entonces uno igual nuevamente el primero
que se nos puede ocurrir es que cuatro
menos b por c sea igual a cero en este
caso que ocurre que veces es igual a
cuatro y es el mismo problema que
teníamos anteriormente así que me tiene
que ser igual a dos y se tiene que ser
igual a 2
y otra vez y ahora estamos suponiendo
que es 2 muy bien entonces van puras
opciones distintas hasta este momento
otra que puede ser es que 4 - bc
por ejemplo por ejemplo 3 no
y realmente realmente podríamos
podríamos hay que pensar si podríamos
tener algo más pero bueno vamos a hacer
ese caso primero 4 menos veces sea igual
a 3 en este caso si restamos 3 de ambos
lados y sumando veces nos queda que b se
ve se tiene que ser igual a 1 b se tiene
que ser igual a 1 y si veces es igual a
1 ya vimos que ve es igual a 1 y c es
igual a 1 y otra vez a es igual a 2
entonces realmente no podemos tener otra
opción
no podemos tener otra opción porque lo
más que le podemos quitar a 4 es
justamente cuatro verdad el mayor valor
que puede tener tomar b por c es cuando
ambos toman su mayor valor que es 2 para
cada uno no entonces después en la única
opción que nos queda es restarle menos
que 4 es decir por ejemplo restarle 1
para que nos dé 3 y ya es la única
opción que nos queda entonces pudimos
enlistar cuatro posibilidades así que
vamos a ver cuáles de estos incisos nos
dan exactamente cuatro por ejemplo éste
a skip estrés entonces aquí tenemos dos
por dos por tres al cuadrado que es 9
menos 2 son
- 2 son 7 si lo estoy haciendo bien
es otra vez 3 al cuadrado son 9 menos 3
aunque ahora sí 9 menos tres son seis
más uno son siete y dos por siete son 14
así que esta opción no coincide con
nuestro resultado vamos a ver este 3 al
cubo son 27 aquí son 27 menos 3 - 1 son
2 al cuadrado son 4 27 menos 423 que
definitivamente no es nuestra opción
vamos a ver aquí tenemos tres menos uno
son dos al cuadrado que son cuatro
entonces cee es una opción
vamos a ver esperemos que la de no sea
una opción para tener ya la respuesta y
tenemos tres menos uno son dos por tres
al cuadrado que son nueve menos dos son
siete que son 14 stade tampoco puede ser
así que los evaluadores consideran en
efecto esta divisa divisibilidad con
números negativos eso lo vemos de
nuestro breve resultado
entonces suponiendo todo esto la única
opción posible que funciona para p igual
a 3 es la c
de ahí que podemos elegir esta este
resultado